– Ja, komm! Leg den Ball rüber.
Komm! Ah! Aber der macht ’n absolut
großartiges Spiel heute.
– Der Müller ist heute aber
auch total gut drauf.
Ja, komm, schieß!
– Ja!
– Ah …
– Mega Chance …
– Und zurück!
Komm, laufen, Jungs!
So rennen doch keine Weltmeister!
– Jetzt nicht aufgeben!
– Selmas Vater weiß jetzt,
dass sie sich mit mir trifft.
– Na und? Sie ist doch erwachsen.
Und außerdem seid ihr
nur Freunde, oder?
– So einfach ist das nicht.
Ihre Eltern sind sehr streng.
Sie sind sauer,
wenn sie sich mit mir trifft.
Und sind sie sauer,
darf Selma nicht rausgehen.
Und darf Selma nicht rausgehen,
seh ich sie nicht.
– Ah …
– Und wenn du sie nicht siehst, dann …
Ich hab schon verstanden.
Heute hast du verloren,
morgen wirst du wieder gewinnen, okay?
– Eislaufen fällt aus.
Und alles andere auch.
Sorry, Nico.
– Tor!
Abseits, Abseits, Abseits, Abseits!